[Music]
this is the story of how the UK invented
the future here in Britain's
manufacturing heartland the Industrial
Revolution began changing everything
we're three centuries ago these first
mills and blast furnaces kick-started
mass production and the greatest
economically in history purling millions
out of poverty
but today when you make pilgrimages to
these sites ground zero of the modern
world it's impossible to avoid another
lesson as the waste going up by
generations of growth and consumption
threatens to cause irreversible damage
to the planet
posing the question can Britain the
country which invented industrialized
pollution become the first major nation
to end it
for much of that history Humberside was
at the heart of Britain's economic
engine oil refineries coal plants
factories and here in Grimsby under the
iconic Victorian tower the fishing
trawlers which fed us like those old
monuments today much of it lies
abandoned only a fraction of the fishing
community remains this is Finn's new
fish market
we have fish coming to the grading area
from all parts of the country and from
abroad it's all sold individually this
is like the last generation
there's not many young merchants on it
right across the road from the fish
market you'll find John and his business
partner Louise's shop they're the last
ones left on the street if you go round
look down all the the side streets and
they've all got a story to tell this was
all full
as little as swap 15 years ago 10 years
ago it was vows bulton
I mean long this was this was a very
busy place normal Rogers then there was
a smokehouse quality Donnelly's now
while you'd bump into the wild cat this
is how it ends up as you can see once
upon a time and that industrial past
Britain and its economy ruled the waves
but there is an alternative darker
version of history in the 18th century
the Industrial Revolution kick-started
economic growth and modern capitalism
but only at the cost of pumping out
millions of tons of carbon into the
atmosphere as the years ticked on by
from iron and steel production to coal
and steam power plants and factories and
for centuries Britain was the only name
in the game the world's economic engine
the world's richest economy and by far
the world's biggest polluter but just
look at what happens at the start of the
20th century America finally begins to
overtake us
but these ever-increasing bars tell
another story the richer we've got the
more we've polluted and it all comes
back to the fact that we never put a
price on waste until now because with
scientists predicting a climate
catastrophe and with China pumping ever
more pollution into the atmosphere the
greatest challenge of the next century
is going to be managing this carbon debt
the debt that Britain started
so what to do about it
John Gunnar is chair of the Committee on
climate change which advises the
government on green policy what we need
to do is to get to the point at which we
are no longer contributing to the growth
of climate change I mean that that is a
duty of to do that because we started
the Industrial Revolution which has
caused the problem and when you start
something and get rich by it then you
have some responsibility to repair it
and now the government have committed to
zero emissions the big questions are how
to do it how much will it cost and might
there even be some money-making
opportunities industry is increasingly
understanding that this is where its
profits going to be I mean there won't
be big oil companies if they stick to
oil so it's existential for them I sense
a huge change a huge change and a huge
opportunity for the humber estuary as
you travel along its banks from Grimsby
- mm - hull you sense a region shifting
its gaze from past glories towards an
industrial revolution in the making a
green industrial revolution a few yards
from those old abandoned fishing shops
and smoke houses you will find this
place this is the base for Oersted once
upon a time Denmark's national oil
company it has now shifted into wind
farms a trade that promises to transform
the local economy
she's got quite a few my my family
members who actually dealt back in the
day in the fish market and over here on
the other side it's it's kind of the
future yeah dave is one of the
apprentices working on keeping those
turbines turning before I got my my job
here I was actually involved in the
company that produced plastic single-use
plastic and it wasn't somewhere that I
wanted to be the employee didn't share
that same ethic that I do I'm quite
passionate about sustainability and
about climate change my generation
always heard stories about how the
fishing industry with it was amazing and
and everyone had money in the pockets
and wanting to spend but I think this
this industry now it's shedding it's
shedding a light and it's given people
hope
now that Grimsby could actually be back
to how it was back to great Grimsby
Britain is unusually well placed to
benefit from wind power but what about
when the wind isn't blowing or for that
matter the Sun isn't shining the answer
is you need backup here at the mouth of
the Humber estuary a lot of the focus is
on what's going on out there offshore
winds and thanks to fools in prices and
technology advances that could provide
the majority of UK power in the future
but if you want a constant stream of
green electricity you actually need to
look inland down the estuary towards
something that on the face of it doesn't
look all that green this is Drax it used
to be the biggest coal-fired power
station in Western Europe today it
mostly burns biomass wood pellets but
they still produce carbon actually more
than coal so they're working on a plan
to remove the co2 emissions from the
chimney and
to affect that process from one ton
again okay how much you pumping out so
we million as you probably gathered this
technology isn't there yet and getting
it there will cost well no one quite
knows frankly we reasons why we're doing
the pilot project here it's actually
work out exactly what we think the costs
to them and you say it's going to be
billions
and then that does have to come out of
people's pockets yes yes so ultimately
so as a society we have to all the side
that is something we wanted it's a
challenge we want to take on and that
that's something that we should pay for
and I believe we showed that it again
it's not for me to decide but a society
will have to absolutely cover the cost
there's no way it's gonna be free it's
not gonna be free but there is a pattern
with expensive things they don't always
happen
back on the road to Grimsby is killing
home that old demolished power station
was supposed to be replaced with a
working carbon capture plant like that
pilot at Drax but full-scale it was due
to be up and running in 2020 next year
but in 2015 the government cancelled it
too expensive and when it comes to
actually imposing the Green taxes to pay
for this stuff it's mostly talk and no
action
consider what happened with petrol taxes
over the past few years in 2010 the
government was planning a big increases
in fuel duties but knowing how unpopular
that would be they lost their nerve and
not just once in fact every single
budget since then the planned increase
in fuel duty has been cancelled so that
even as the emissions from the vehicle
sector have increased the amount of tax
we get from it has actually gone down in
real terms might that be about to change
though a new sky data poll has found
that the proportion of people supporting
green taxes is up from 37% in 2015 to
52% today however when asked whether
they wanted to pay more in petrol taxes
only 36% of people said yes forty-nine
percent of people still said no and
that's the problem with going green
everyone loves it in theory up until
they're told they'll have to pay for it
especially if like the fish workers in
Grimsby all that green investment is
spent on the other side of the fence
when people say Oh it'll be great
because you know Grimsby is going to be
a pioneer and clean energy and that's
going to be the investments over there
where the
one of the things that they say you know
for together kind of green economy
they're going to have to raise green
taxes and one of the green taxes is fuel
duty would that be a concern something
to some skepticism about the grand green
vision the government is quite keen on
even though even though that might be
bringing some jobs yeah maybe
it's probably moving do you know anybody
that works on the wind farms cuz I go
yet the shift is coming we'll also have
to replace nearly every boiler and
heating system in the country
and since there's no sign yet of
electric planes the amount of aviation
we permit will have to be limited with
major implications for airports wanting
to build them runways if he throw is
built it has to be built within the
envelope but of course it has on
knock-on effects it means you can't
build similar things elsewhere in the
country you're not going to be able to
have expansions of a different kind
elsewhere you can't heavy it and other
things one implication is that if the
Green Revolution takes off so much that
Humberside also wants a new runway it
may not be allowed yet another trade off
will have to confront but according to
the man who wrote one of the first major
reports on the economics of climate
change we're running out of time the
science is much scarier
it was even in 2006 well very long list
it was pretty scary then but he's much
worse now good I mean the concentrations
been going up emissions have been going
up a lot of the effects have been coming
through faster than we thought the
science is definitely more worrying
perhaps the scariest thing is that there
is only so much we can do the idea is
for Britain to freeze its bar by 2050
has one net zero emissions really means
but we're only one part of the story
what about other countries Britain may
still be one of the world's biggest
carbon debtor's but right now most of
the pollution is coming from China and
they're still going through their
version of our industrial revolution but
who knows perhaps in future it won't
just be those old industrial revolution
landmarks like the first iron bridge
people come to Britain to see will our
descendants pay homage to these new
monuments of this green industrial
revolution as symbols of how we learnt
how to grow without polluting the earth
[Music]